all right let's make a star hello good
evening and welcome everybody to
tonight's meeting of the east area
planning committee my name is Danny
Kendall I'll be chairing tonight's
meeting in accordance with the rules and
procedure set out on the front inside
cover of the agendas that you've got
before we get started bit of
housekeeping just to remind members of
the public to please make sure their
mobile phones turned off or certainly on
to silent please and to also inform you
that tonight's meeting is being recorded
and live webcast so it is going out live
on the website at the moment and will be
available for you to all review at your
leisure should you wish in the next day
or two as well on the council website a
few introductions from the people other
people are front as well on my far right
is Allen sheepy from committee services
then Mason Nash legal services District
Council on my left
Andy Carter our Planning Manager for the
evening then John Wilbraham and Erin
weather Stone who are both officers here
at district council we will be
presenting applications for us tonight
as well right ok that's our introduction
is done apologies for absence please so
that one apology from councillor Crump
the Vice Chairman thank you and
disclosure of interests from the
committee
yes thanks mr. chairman it's application
five on the agenda mr. chairman on
visiting the site
I actually met I have a conversation
with the I believe it's the neighbors of
this proposed site I think it's table
cross the B&B just met them didn't have
a conversation but around there so it
won't influence my decision Thank You
councillor Donnell Thank You chair just
for item number eight on the agenda as
well remember I'll be standing down and
also speaking okay and council fielding
just the item numbers okay okay okay it
won't be an issue when it was just
conversation in terms of what how much
sort of okay oh sorry the microphone
wasn't on for that apologies people
thank you okay that's fine so we can go
to our first item tonight I'm just gonna
read you the agenda slightly because
we've got one of our items coming off
the agenda so to save anybody waiting
for that one it will just move that one
to the front so we'll do light in seven
first because that one's being deferred
which is I application reference 17 / 0
0 6 3 2 / ful Josh that's you Andy isn't
it can you just very briefly the reason
for it being deferred or proposed for
deferred yes sure it's being deferred
because it's an invalid application at
the moment the applicants are realizing
the sign notices okay well I'll happen
to propose that we defer that in a
second of the hope please
fielding thank you all those in favor of
deferring that application please show
thank you so item 7 is deferred right
okay we can get back a normal running
order then so that means we start with
item 3 she's found on page 1 of your
agendas tonight in his application
reference 17 / 0 - 0 7 0 / ful and is
the land adjacent to the clock house and
stone Croft barn upper brailles
and is the erection of dwelling creation
of new vehicle access improvement of
servicing an existing public
right-of-way and all associated works
presenting officer is John Wilbraham
John rabe over to you thank you Jeff the
application is
gated in Upper brailles on an empty
parcel of land that's currently used for
grazing the site is identified in the
redline outlined there the current site
as you can see is empty passive land
between two existing properties it
slopes down away from the road the plan
shows the site layout with the property
for bed detached dwelling located just
slightly behind the street frontage of
the two adjacent properties a public
right away runs alongside the southern
boundary of the site and as also it's
within the Cotswolds area of outstanding
natural beauty the design is fairly
simple its brick built with a slate roof
it's simple detailing around the sills
and the eaves these are the side
elevations as you can see as a rear
single-story projection which was
reduced down in size during the course
of the application the height is similar
to the neighboring property to the north
which is Myrtle Gardens which is also a
recent new built property during the
course of the application concerns were
raised with surface water flooding it's
in a low risk surface water flooding
area and a map was provided or plan
rather showing a attenuation tank in the
rear garden here and a drainage channel
to be installed at the front that would
run down and drain into that attenuation
tank it's also proposed to landscape the
front so that the finished floor level
of the property is above the flood water
level of 300 mil so the the front will
be excavated to ensure that it takes
place I'll move on to the site photos
here's a view from Gillette's Lane which
is opposite the site as you can see
empty parcel of land here's the current
access to the public right-of-way which
runs along this boundary this is myrtle
Gardens and then there's another
property over here which is a stone
Croft at Barnes this is a view looking
back down towards a site again we've got
myrtle gardens and
for ground and the converted barns in
the background stone Croft and that's
their clock house there this is a view
from the opposite end so again we've got
the stowecroft barns there myrtle
gardens and a range of various materials
of other properties down there and a
fairly landscaped street frontage this
is a view from within the site as you
can see the land slopes down away from
the road down here we've got the
neighboring properties and drill it's
Lane runs up there the public
right-of-way
runs along here this is a view from the
top end of jeddaks lane which the public
right-of-way runs down and runs down
here and continues down there from here
these limited views of the proposed
dwellings you to exist in landscaping
further down the site Jill its Lane
rather the site again is in the
background there with a public
right-of-way running along the side
boundary again fairly limited views
given the landscape and that's on Jill
its Lane this is a view of Myrtle
Gardens which is located to the north as
you can see there is existing
landscaping to the side is proposed to
increase this on the application site to
I'm sure there's no overlooking a ground
floor level as you can see they have a
existing single-story extension similar
to a element similar to the proposal
with a sort patio area there this is the
clock house which is converted barns on
the southern side of the application
slope to the public right-of-way runs
along the foreground there and these are
windows into bedroom bedroom and a
kitchen I believe this is just a view
from the road again of the the clock
house there the right of way down here
and the stone Croft barns here
there was concern raised as well about
the materials proposed myrtle gardens
was approved and the materials
discharged were not overly in keeping
with the area it's accepted the
applicants have indicated they will use
this particular brick type which is a
Cotswolds blend is considered to be much
more in keeping with the the
I've got a couple of that's another
picture of the brick from the builders
website and the updates to the
application there was two updated plans
one was the slight layout just to show
the drainage channel and also the
drainage plan itself there are six
additional letters of support received
two letters from the same objector
raising concerns with the surface water
again we had an informal response from
the Environment Agency I spoke to them
over email and there was also updated
and fluid drainage section to go with
the report the recommendation is to
approve for the reasons set out in the
report gem thank you right
okay good our first speaker a counselor
Rosenthal please from brailles Parish
Council okay we'll get the presentation
loaded up for you counselor you have
three minutes if you'd remain seated for
any questions at the end over to you as
you've heard this product lies within an
area of outstanding natural beauty which
is afforded according to the NPP F the
highest level of protection in relation
to landscape and natural beauty
paragraph 85 over the countryside and
right-of-way at 2006 that with regard to
an area of outstanding natural beauty
irrelevant authority shall have regard
to conserving enhancing the natural
beauty that the area of outstanding
natural beauty erecting a house and
obliterating various views from various
points does the opposite to claim the
development would preserve the scenic
beauty of the AR NB is untenable because
that beauty resides in the landscape the
1998 village design statement adopted as
a supplementary planning guidance by the
Stratford Council identified the view
we're talking about is key one of those
green fingers intrinsic to the upper
brailles landscape to permit building on
its it's an extremely dangerous
precedent for developing and
obliterating all such green fingers
including the allotments the
Neighborhood Development Plan is highly
advanced due to goes to cabinet in July
it was unexpectedly delayed until
November by the previously unannounced
requirement for a strategic
environmental
assessment our consultants concluded
significant effects on the environment
may occur as a result of the NDP the
topic likely to be affected his
landscape contry to the planning
statement submitted the paddock is not
within but outside the built-up area
boundary to find and agreed in the draft
NDP in accordance with advice from
Stratford Council nor is it an allocated
site within that plan
Stratford Council has robust housing
supply to date 48 over 84 stipulated
units in brailles have been built or
have planning permission in June 2016
Stratford council refused an appeal in
brailles
on grounds including the existing supply
of housing being such there was no
compelling evidence that developed that
site as is the case here to future
housing will be delivered by the
neighbourhood development plan on
identified sites within the built-up
area of boundary the cutoff date is 2031
the paddock is subject to surface water
flooding at risk up to 300 millimetres
it appears no flood risk assessment has
been provided to prove the proposed
house would be safer its life time
neither the Environment Agency nor
Warwickshire County Council appear to
have declare the proposed sites safe
from surface water flood risk once it's
built on this paddock landscape and
views are forever lost
is this a legacy we wish to bequeath
Stratford Council also rejected the 2016
appeal because the proposed I'm quoting
the proposed development would result in
significant a demonstrable harm in terms
of his impact on the landscape character
and visual immunity of the area that
applies here to the parish council
supports development in brailles
is identified sites where the remainder
of the houses stipulated including
social housing can get built but it also
has a duty of custodianship towards the
village and its surroundings more
generally tend okay sorry you just cut
off though there sorry about that
excellent timing by the way any
questions please the parish council go
now to our next speaker mr. Walker
please come for your Walker
welcome sir yes we just press the button
the Midler
excellent you also have three minutes
who remain safe any questions of the
head over to you mr. chairman speakers
owner of stone craft barn which is
immediately adjacent to the site under
discussion they also speak on behalf of
my neighbors and other residents who
have already submitted objections to
this application which you will have
seen we are upper brailles
and we care about our village we care
about how it looks how it works and how
we live as a community we've all
contributed in several ways to the
brailles neighborhood development plan
which has been produced to shape
developments within this village this
plan updates the views of the 1998
brailles village design statement which
was also produced to guide an influence
change in the village consistently these
have emphasized the value of the green
fingers of land which intersperse the
dwellings of Uffa brailles
offering views and open spaces for the
village linking to the wider landscape
this application is a proposal to build
on one of these green fingers the
Neighborhood Development Plan addresses
all the needs for residential
development within the village over the
next 10 years it excludes any
development on these green areas there
is no need for this speculative dwelling
further brailles is in an area of
outstanding natural beauty the built-up
area boundary has always run through the
site and is all but confirmed as running
right up to the road between Myrtle
Gardens and stone Croft bond it has been
in the past this boundary must preclude
any building on this site I would ask
the committee to acknowledge the
Neighborhood Development plan the
built-up area of boundary and the wishes
of the residents of upper brailles and
dismiss this application it is neither
needed nor wished for
could set a precedent and would destroy
forever a special part of our green
environment thank you thank you any
questions please yes say mr. chairman
hello mr. Humphrey I perhaps I should
have asked this of the House Counsel but
do you know if there's any consultation
between the developer and Parish Council
with consultation in the village okay
okay shake your head and yes and also
okay miss did you say that you reach
your housing quota sorry have you
reached your housing quota in thanks
mister thank you
any other questions that case mr. Walker
thank you very much go to the applicants
age in there please Jane Cashmore sorry
mr. chairman um I it has just occurred
to me that through my office connection
that we are involved with Myrtle Gardens
so I will sit down
I have those reminded by the pictures so
know that if you'll excuse me thank you
okay no that's entirely correct
procedure that's fantastic thank you
welcome right
sorry so you have a total of six minutes
previous to speaks combined if you'd
remain seated for any questions over to
you thank you good evening I wanted to
use my time to highlight some of the key
issues and touch briefly on some of the
objections which have been raised the
call strategy identifies brailles as a
category to local service village the
policy allows for approximately eighty
four houses in brailles and to date
there have been 44 committees or built
policy does therefore allow for further
growth of
the call strategy allows small-scale
development within village confines and
the proposed single dwelling is
small-scale development
turning to the matter of whether the
site is in the village confines the
officer report correctly states that
there's no defined built-up area
boundary around the settlement at this
point in time the case officer has put
forward his reasons as to why the site
can be considered in the village
confines he says the site is an infill
plot between existing houses that the
development would fit into the
settlement pattern and that the site is
well related to services and facilities
added to this I have also looked at
other evidence documents on the screen
firstly the site is within the village
boundary that was part of an old local
plan the neighborhood development plan
is emerging and the village boundaries
in the process of being defined it
refers to using the old local plan
boundary as a basis to define the new
map the new boundary there are two plans
currently showing on the neighbourhood
department plan website one in their
September 2017 version that's shown on
the screen as the June 2017 version
which shows the site within the proposed
boundary then there is another plan on
the website showing the site outside the
boundary but there's a note alongside
this which says the built afire boundary
is not correct a revised boundary will
be decided by the NP committee on the
basis of all this information without
there being a defined boundary the
evidence points to a logical and
reasonable conclusion that the site lies
within the physical confines of rails
turning to more detailed matters local
objection has been raised in terms of
impact on the AO and B the council's
landscape officer does not agree and
considers harm would not arise to the a
OMB the existing footpath would be
retained enhanced and would still
provide access through to the land at
the rear and beyond these open views
will therefore not be completely lost
with regards to the comments we've heard
this evening from the parish council
about Greenfingers having looked at
the emerging neighborhood development
plan the plan shown within that does not
identify the site as a green finger and
there's a plan which simply says this is
a place marker for a future plan so that
hasn't been determined yet it should
also be noted that there are many
letters of support which have been
received in relation to the development
you'll see that on the update sheet
finding that this site is appropriate
for development in terms of design we
have amended our plans during the course
of the application to take on board the
planning officers feedback we've reduced
the size of the dwelling lowered the
ridge height to match Myrtle Gardens
alongside and added more landscaping
Myrtle Gardens is a dwelling which has
attracted a lot of negative reaction to
its appearance I don't disagree however
what has happened alongside the site is
not a reason to react negatively to this
proposal as some third-party letters
state this proposal has a different
design and materials were she County
Council rights-of-way welcome the
footpath improvements the applicant will
be changing the style to a kissing gait
and improving the footpaths surface this
is not a requirement but planning gained
in terms of highways there are no
objections from Warwickshire County
Council highways turning to drainage
matter is detailed in the update sheet
but in brief I've spoken with several
drainage engineers they advised the
Environment Agency figures are
approximate and that an extreme rainfall
event would have to occur to result in
the extent of such flooding that said
they advise some mitigation to protect
the pros proposed house is necessary to
ensure the ground floor finished floor
levels and or the front door threshold
level is elevated above the immediate
ground levels surrounding we've provided
for this on the plans the ground levels
on the driveway enable any excess flows
to be directed around and not into the
building the drainage engineers have
said they would also expect soaker ways
to be considered along with a disposal
to a water course or available sewer
system they consider the use of a
storage tank we we have proposed would
be fair as this is a single residential
property the planning officer has
recommended a drainage condition to
which the
applicant has no objection in terms of
direct consultation responding to
counsel emails this question earlier
there has been no direct consultation
but what I would say is that careful
regard has been given to the
Neighborhood Development Plan in
preparing this proposal which does
reflect the views of the local community
in summary the applicant has carefully
designed the proposed dwelling the site
is located in a sustainable location for
small-scale development and the
proposals have been amended following
feedback from the planning officer there
are no objections from County highways
ecology footpaths and your landscape
officer I hope you're able to support
your officers recommendation thank you
for listening thank you any questions
counselor fielding
just trying to work out the NPD June
2017 it's so small it's very difficult
to see exactly where that finger comes
in on is there an area of enlarged
no it appears that the the site is
actually further or sorry the boundary
the black boundary shows it goes around
the back of the site rather than the
front of the site which is what's shown
on the previous plan is that the case
yes so if you can see that plan on the
property just to the north which is
Myrtle Gardens the that boundary line
pretty much comes in line I would say
with the the rear of Myrtle Gardens so
the application site does slightly
project beyond it but what I would say
is that as a draft boundary and it
hasn't been defined can't slurp Mills
nice ratio hello Jane
good to see you change and you mentioned
in your report there that it was no
obstruction or doesn't obscure the view
to Aon BL comic there's a house put
there how can it not obscure the view of
a OMB so what I was trying to say is
that the views from citing the house
there that the views of the a OMB are
not completely lost because the public
footpath which she runs along the
southern boundary still remains open
will be improved and therefore there
will be public access passed the house
and beyond and I think as as you saw
from John's photos during the his
presentation the views from Gillett
slain looking across the actual house
wouldn't be visible from those views but
it will be a certain amount will be
obscured by the house when you're
standing directly on the road Lydia
looking at it then yes you will see a
house in instead of a grass grass field
the whole of the villages within the
area of outstanding natural beauty the
core strategy allows for 84 houses so in
some place or other the views of the IMP
of the a OMB will be affected by
dwellings
yes council bans
I did go and look at the site they're
sick it looks to me as though coming
down that little Lane is the only way
that you can actually see the hay from
from higher viewpoint you obviously yes
so I would agree with that and obviously
the views do change depending on the
season the other question was the
footpath looked as there it needed
although it was obviously a rule for
that sort of attention you're not going
to yeah so with liaise with county
footpaths and they want the final
details secured by condition but in
effect is currently a style there which
would be removed replaced with her
kissing gate and the surface would be
resurfaced with the material which the
county council wish to see but we're
gonna have a gate that will be disabled
yeah I mean certainly the the applicant
it's quite open to that
the final details will be resolved
through condition if that's what we're
actually hands council foot possible
then that can be secured Thank You
councillor O'Donnell were you indicating
it was just a couple of things and we
said that um leaving Jane you said that
the fuse would not be completely lost
but what will actually be left given it
is an air of outstanding natural beauty
so the the if you're standing literally
on the road we're looking towards the
proposed dwelling I don't know if a plan
can be put up to show you that but the
the the house does not cover the entire
width of the plot and what I was trying
to say about views not being completely
lost is that this is a public footpath
so people are free to walk down there
and to see the long beyond so that
that's what I was trying to refer to
when I said the views will not be
completely lost thank you can I just add
on to that
given it is an area outstanding natural
beauty and people probably want to use a
public footpath to go and look at the
views why has there not been any
communication between developer and and
the locals I can't answer that directly
why there hasn't been any direct
conversation other than to say the
comments which I've made about the
neighborhood development plan and I'll
just reiterate that your landscape
officer doesn't consider there to be any
harm to the a OMB thank you
yes councillor fielding the picture that
was put up by the parish council can you
put that one back up again
it appears to have a head coming out
which is which could or is that like if
you be the boundary of the new property
because you've got further back you've
got a not yet another hedge which in
some respects and summer rather obscures
the Aon V years of you I must confess
I'm not exactly sure whereabouts on the
site that photo is taken but if we go
back to the planning officers photo
showing the site from the road you can
see the the boundaries in full and none
of the those existing rear boundaries
would be the rear boundary of the garden
so I can't comment on the parishroofer
okay are there any other questions if
not thank you very much really okay we
can get our ward member next simply is
councillor gray welcome councillor gray
so you have five minutes but you know
the routine oh thank you Kevin
my purpose tonight is to support the
parish council in their opposition to
this application general I read the
officers report and with the greatest of
respect I fail to understand quite the
judgments within it or agree with the
conclusions the report seems to express
as much concern for the houses either
side or the ones opposite as it does for
the impact on the whole village and its
residents and the report considers that
the new house will not adversely impact
on the views within the village but as
has been observed you know how is that
possible when there's a house built in
front of it this site identified in the
droll AB draft Wales neighborhood
development plan as a green finger to be
protected it's also considered to be one
of the most significant views in the
village by the village design statement
but it's not just a view it's the way in
which brailers connects to the
wrong community and to the landscape and
its agricultural roots rather than
rather than just a simple view animals
can graze right up to the road that runs
through the the center of the village
generally it's a community that can
still boast a eight blacksmith
I I think the report underestimates the
important of this site importance of
this site I hope you'll refuse the
application thank you any questions to
the warden on counts Mills
oh sorry through indicated sorry no
other questions
councillor gray thank you very much
right
let's go two points of clarification
don't have any yes and focuses are you
there lost polka simply put on myrtle
house and which is that one there that
photograph on the left yeah it also
showed a photograph of an extension at
the back was that could he put that one
over there don't excellent I think it's
just
who knows a close-up of it it was an
excellent why have I got that wrong no
it seemed to me sorry it just seemed a a
totally different brick that was all
know that the extension on the back
that's what we mentioned I think it
might have been part of the original
scheme it's a completely different brick
to the one proposed yes it seemed to me
a scheme is it perhaps it's not part of
the application no no I know I just I
was going to come on to you referring to
the photo that was the other one that
materials photo yes yes that was I think
just produced by the building yeah
sample picture confused of kinds in mr.
Jenner so thank you okay councillor
fielding can you clear up for me the the
difference between the June 17 a finger
that was shown on by the agent and the
one that is actually being portrayed in
the in the paper and the documentation
we've had it seems that either from what
the right-hand part of that ducting webs
that picture is saying showing is that
the still to be defined revised boundary
will be decided by the the NP committee
do we know if that's being brought
forward I think it's still pending the
situation by the committee I don't think
there's any defined built-up area
boundary as yet in the neighborhood
development plan so therefore if that
June 17 is version is correct then we
are looking at infill there is that
correct it's just worth clarifying that
there is no defined built area boundary
within the development plan for brailles
so what the officer is
sassing is whether he considers it
within the physical confines so there is
no line drawn as a be built area
boundary as yet within the adopted plan
if the neighborhood development plan is
made and therefore becomes adopted that
will then define a built-up area
boundary but as we understand that
that's not yet taking place so just
clarify some neither the pictures we've
currently on screen none of them are
really relevant to our decision at all
that's correct
it's an assessment of physical confines
okay okay any other points clarification
yes counselor dollar is this a green
finger size because it's been I'm
confused by what's been presented this
evening on that I couldn't see reference
to this particular pass will be in a
green finger in the current development
plan no no no the points clarification
should we get a debate council bonds I
did manage to get over the the star
which needed repair look at the
outstanding natural beauty and to be
honest like some of the photos there was
a lot of trees in the way obviously in
the winter that would be beautiful but
looking at the bar next door the
conversion and the new house on the
other side and I can't really see put
foot in personally looking at the road
up as it and the house was on one side
so that the view still would be there so
as far as I can see him I appreciate
what the parish council has said and
none of us want development in in our
villages but I would go along with the
officers recommendation when I'm
proposing if you work but I mean you
know I have concern I did
but the whole area is is obviously
beautiful but I don't think useful I
think it could enhance it thank you
thank you yes councilman thanks Mitchum
yes son I'm for sure I disagree with
councillor Barnes there Sarge hey Pete
yeah I feel when I look at the society
it does obscure the view of our area of
outstanding beauty and it's a little
else has been put on Moodle house next
door no just if this goes through the
goodness say we can't have the same
brick it just does not fit in with the
area from obtained for my view it just
spoils this look of Erebus to any beauty
another pocket of land it's dawn once
it's gone it's gone forever
so mr. Chairman I won't be supporting
the officers recommendation on this one
thank you yes counts O'Donnell I think
the only people that we enjoying the
view if this house goes through other
people in the house and or some
concerned about the lack of
communication between the applicant and
the locals considering it is no
outstanding natural beauty and also that
we're not paying an awful lot of
attention to the parish council and the
religious feedback on their development
plan and what they're hoping for and I
think that that's a worrying precedent
to set so I won't be supporting the
office recommendation yeah no makes this
remind me of course at the end the dead
development plan neighbor to help plan
it's only in it very early well an early
stage has not been adopted yet I fully
understand that it's just that they are
all giving us feedback what they want
for their area and I think we need to
take that into consideration but I do
appreciate it's not for you dr. Joe
thank you that's fulfilling the the
common tree the numbers that the village
needs to believe it no deed there is a
shortage of building
houses that are referred to in the
report here also this at least I believe
that they are leaving sufficient gap for
the footpath down the side of the
building which will open up behind the
house to the a O and B and therefore
will not stop the enjoyment of walking
in the area
it is infill and I believe from what I
understand they are using a more cops
world colored brick in keeping with the
neighbor in the neighboring building
so therefore the house on the north side
which is a horrible colored brick or out
of keeping anyway I think that this
would be more in keeping with the the
the brickwork that currently in the in
the village I will support councillor
Barnes thank you I'm really struggling
with the so I think what for me the
difficulty is I'm trying to tell you
what as with all these things it is it's
to do with the air about stunning
natural beauty and the impact this is
going to have on all that now understand
we'll be losing a field that is lovely
it looks really nice I get that but
what's its impact on the on the only
actual scenery behind it other than
having half this houses all weight all
the way along that road and I'm
struggling to see the real harm that's
that's what's concerning me on the a ho
and B I think I'm varying towards
supporting the officers recommendation
on this one it's not been proposed or
seconded yet I don't know if anybody
wants to go to that Oh
council knows what you're proposing and
it's been seconded back out there we
come high council feeling should we go
to the boat okay all those in favor of
granting the application please show
one two three four chairmen and there's
against to chairman in case the
committee resolves to grant application
refers 17 / 0 to 0 7 0 / ful
let's move on to item four tonight's
agenda which is found on page 13 and is
application reference 17 / 0 to 1 to 0 /
ful and is the Westcott house south
south nap to home Hill is the conversion
of an existing bond to form a
residential unit with associated parking
internal access and ancillary works
presenting officer insert John Wilbraham
again Joe thank you thank you Jeff
the site is located off the a 4 to 5 on
the approach to Knapton as you can see
it's located here and the confines of
Knapton village you consider to be
further to the east the proposal is to
convert an existing c-shaped portal bond
that shares an access with the Westcott
house property but then has its own
access off that it would be converted
into a dwelling plans currently it's an
open sided portal bond these elements
being open around a concrete forecourt
and the outs outside elevations being a
mix of Hidden Mist timber boarding and
concrete bricks as well as metal
sheathing with I think the cement fiber
roof it's the elevations presently the
proposal would then replace all of the
external materials and build on the
existing portal frame replacing with
reclaimed brick and black stained timber
with a slate roof there'd be no change
to the height at all but it would be a
complete rebuild around the existing
structure I've got some pictures for you
this is a view from the shared access so
this would then be the access up to the
barn which you can just see in the
background there this is the open-sided
element around the existing concrete
forecourt you can see the timber
boarding and concrete blocks that would
be replaced again this is part of the
the metal sheathing so again that would
go as with the roofing material and be
replaced with new new elements that's
just a side elevation and that's the
view across to
the a four to five this isn't part of
the application site there are limited
views of the barn
due to the landscaping until you're
further down a four to five in that
direction in terms of updates there's no
objection from environmental health to
this game and that was the only one the
recommendation is to refuse being
contrary to a s ten a conversion in
countryside and the recommendations
refused as set out in the report yeah
thank you John all right on to our first
speaker for this one which is Gordon
Clark please that one he'll parish
council welcome Council remain seated
for any questions at the end I'll give
you a warning at ten seconds of that so
okay thank you I'm here on behalf of
Noctem Parish Council to give the
reasons for our support for the
application and our submission noted
that which has just been mentioned the
proposal does not encroach into open
countryside is not detrimental to the
existing site and the price council also
notice that the site Falls just outside
the proposed built-up area boundary but
as is there's a light for light
replacement on the same footprint
footprint it should be supported there
was of course a detailed debate and the
council regarding the application and
normally Knapton Parish Council would
certainly be against building in open
countryside outside of the village
confines so we do appreciate the
planning officers concerns regarding
this in the committee's report submitted
the application seems to falter on three
policy issues resulting in the Planning
Officers recommendation to refuse the CS
one CS 15 and a s ten regarding a s ten
which is probably irrelevant the bond
does sit in an isolated position in
relationship to the nearest next
property the Blue has to the east which
is the first has passed Wescott as you
enter naps and on the hill
but the Parish Council looked at it from
making use of an existing building
without enlarging the footprint or Ridge
height there is existing access and no
objections from highways a fundamental
issue that swayed my view in particular
was the fact that the open field at the
moment separating Wescott house and the
blue house is in the process of full
planning application following outline
permission being granted this is to
build for detached 4-bedroom open market
houses this will of course closed the
gap and no longer will Wescott house be
viewed as isolated from the village in
my view that divert that developing the
field is far more unsustainable in open
countryside outside the village confines
much more than Westgate has the
application which sits within the
boundary of Westgate house and in our
view not dentin but detrimental to the
existing site or immediate environment
thank you thank you mr. Larkin any
questions
council bonds it could be views and
sustainable because there are no direct
links to the village I think maybe maybe
were you when you said under sustainably
did you meet were you referring to the
other because referring to the field
that has been developed yeah next which
obviously which you think is more
unsustainable yeah we should see that
yes counts the building which plans our
neighboring field is that the the field
you're referring to the one in the
center yeah that one there
hundred under development at the moment
yes that's under an application and
that's the one you think is
unsustainable
well the parish council view when the
application came to us from the cou cube
application our views our views which
are on the sides do say that okay did
you have another question
any other questions for the parish yeah
that case miss okay thank you very much
go to the DLP consultants on behalf of
the applicants Sinead turbo please hello
welcome
so you also have three minutes remain
seated for any questions at the end over
to you okay the reasonable distance from
the mic it's okay good evening ladies
and gentlemen the proposed development
comprises the conversion of an existing
barn to a dwelling the barn is located
adjacent to West courthouse and members
may recall a recent planning approval
for four dwellings on the land between
West courthouse and blue house the
application site constitutes brownfield
land the redevelopment of brownfield
land is supported by the National
Planning Policy framework at paragraph
111 provided it is not of high
environmental value the officers report
confirms that the development is
acceptable in respect of the landscape
and character of the area the proposed
development would in fact improve views
on entering the village by refurbishing
the barn while maintaining its
agricultural appearance local Planning
Policy contained within the core
strategy places a strong emphasis on the
reuse of brownfield land policy AS tens
specifically supports three years of
brownfield land in countryside and vegan
villages
I'll be it's subject to materials
restrictions the officers report has
confirmed that the construction
materials of stained black timber walls
and slate would retain the agricultural
appearance of the building that suits
the site however the applicant would be
happy to accept any materials conditions
including use of bricks
the officers report confirms that the
proposed works would remain within the
footprint of the existing barn and that
the proposed style and finish of the
building would retain an agricultural
appearance the height of the building
would also be retained as it currently
is for this reason the design and
appearance of the building has been
deemed to be acceptable the development
would not harm the amenity of any
neighboring properties or land in fact
no neighbors have objected to the
application it has been confirmed that
the development would be capable of
providing safe access and adequate
parking there far there are no highway
safety concerns the only outstanding
issue is the site's relationship to the
village the site is within the 30 mile
per hour limits of the village and the
recently approved development of four
dwellings between blue house and Wescott
house has extended the built-up part of
the village to the site in any case
members would be comfortable in
approving the application based on
paragraph 111 of the National Planning
Policy flame framework which supports
development on brownfield land thank you
thank you very much any questions please
from the committee counsel bond
in the three objections one says it's
detrimental to be and baby you might a
better answer that I didn't understand
it I thought the question can you repeat
it was a bit muffled sorry okay we'll
leave it any other questions okay that
case thank you very much for your time
okay don't have a ward member I don't
think I can't see counsel Williams in
the room so points of clarification any
counsel Mills mr. Chen but John could
you put up again the the actual site
yeah sort of I'm in the photograph them
so I don't that's it and then can you
show me their photographs on the back of
the pond where it's kind of a can you
put the arrow exactly where can be it
will be this is not part of the varlets
yeah that's fine okay the point is
clarification okay
if we go to the debate counts fielding
on the grounds that it is a brownfield
site and it is an old agricultural
building that is no longer serving a
useful purpose and it is within the 30
mile an hour speed limit and slowly the
village incra is encroaching out to it I
don't see any reason for refusing it
because otherwise just going to be
allowed to go become derelict and be an
eyesore for the village so I will not
support what the
planning cancer mills thanks miss chim
yeah I don't we've set a precedent for
ourselves on the other dwellings of
inputs that you know and then when
they've Jason field again when I you
know it's a phone John up find out
exactly where it was because even
Wescott house didn't have a name on it
but looking over and seeing this spot I
you know I struggling to find what the
harm was to be honest so I'm fortunate
John I go against the officers
recommendation on this Thank You counsel
bonds got you next three use of an
agriculture building which appears to be
within the village boundary that's my
thoughts it tells them has the bricks up
to the right height so they can be used
under bu the system so far as I'm
concerned like the first speaker I think
it could announce the area to Billings
have the four has is not been approved
or started then it might have been in
open countryside but I don't think it is
now lovely view and change your address
or chip I see no problem we keep our
quality proposed that if you want but
okay I'll take the proposition so do you
have a second counts fielding thank you
second every else want to speaking the
debate at this point counsel Perry I
think quite a bit already being said but
I concur with my colleagues I'm sitting
opposite can't slow Donnelly I can care
with council Perry you're carrying with
people who've just spoken say they're
all in agreement
thank you okay so I'm sensing a moving
in a direction so I need a clear reason
for
we believe are we saying correct me if
I'm wrong that you feel this is not
within the open countryside and it would
actually be reusing tissues can we say
no harm - yeah I forget yeah if I could
just come in with one point of
clarification and just checking the
National Planning Policy framework on
the definition of previously developed
land which is brownfield land it
excludes land that has been occupied by
agricultural or forestry buildings so it
was just that there was quite a bit of
discussion about being a brownfield site
therefore it is and obviously the other
aspects you've discussed in terms of is
it or is it not within the physical
confines continues so I'm and correctly
saying really this whole case boils down
to whether or not we interpret this has
been in the open countryside or not
correct
that's the item one that John has
established reason for refusal the
second item is that it's not considered
a building capable of conversion for
residential use as set out in the policy
a s-10 part d but obviously if members
consider otherwise then we can look at
conditions okay right as far as I can
see mr. chairman are they correct height
for keq improvement both of which means
development even in an area that isn't
it comes out to our interpretation I can
see the okay Castle fielding open
countryside bit further up the road
towards Sodom you've got what what used
to be an old Trading Estate so this very
much is sort of on the fringes of the
village and the Trading Estate so it is
enclosed within I would have thought the
developed part of the village and we've
given the permission for those four
houses therefore we're allowing the
whole thing to encroach up to and then
redefining where F and Country
and I think it's really is the other
side of what was the former Trading
Estate which I whether it's got Planning
Commission still I don't know but all
right I think we've heard this and I
think we've stated where we're going
with him where the committee's in terms
of conditions of either standard set of
conditions would this also include
removal of PD rights as well right I'm
just I'm just checking we're all called
me to be comfortable with removal of
permitted development rights though with
this okay
right okay so the standard conditions
with the removal of PD rights okay we
have a proposition from Council bounce
that's seconded by Councillor Fielding
yeah we've confirmed it with the reasons
how we believe it not being country so
that's fine okay should go to the vote
all those in favor of granting the
application please show unanimous thank
you therefore the key resolves to grant
application reference 17 such as 0 to 1
to 0 such ful for the reasons given and
with the conditions as well so we moved
to item 5 on the agenda okay item 5 is
on page 23 and this is application
reference 17 slash is zero one zero zero
four slash ful and is oakwoods house
Green Lane ox Hill and it's for the
erection of two new dwellings including
associated works and there's an
alteration to a previous planning
application 16 / 0 0 6 7 - / ful so the
presenting officer is Erin whether stone
Erin you ready to go
thank you to the application sight line
to the west of ox hills settlement as
identified by the black dot on this plan
auxins identified as a category for
local service village within the
council's of dr. core strategy site
light to the west of the village
conservation area which is identified by
the pink line on this plan have falls in
an area of medium archaeological
interest this slide identifies a
application site outlined in red the
application site lies to the north of
Green Lane and falls within the garden
of Oakwood house located to the south of
the site planning permission is sought
for the erection of two detached
four-bedroom dwellings with a shared
detached garage and particular access
from Green Lane to the south of the
application site closest neighboring
dwellings lie to the south of the site
and include stable craft to the west
which is also a bed-and-breakfast and
Oakwood house to the south the number
extent permissions exist within close
proximity to the application site which
will be identified later within this
presentation this slide shows the
proposed site plan which identifies the
siting of the two dwellings and the
detached garage you can see that's one
and two closest neighbors are also
visible which is stable craft here and
oak woods house to the south parking
areas provided for the dwellings in
between the built form and to the east
of the application site private garden
areas were also provided so Gardens here
and here
and parking with the detached carriage
in the center of the site the access
proposed goes between the gardens a
stable craft and upwards house and
follows down to the road in a southerly
direction to the north extent planning
permission has been granted for for
dwellings which you can see on this plan
to the north all of the dwellings would
share this access down to Green Lane
this slide shows the proposed floor
plans and elevations of plot 1 the
accommodation would be set across two
levels with four bedrooms at first floor
and a separate sitting room sturdy and
open plan living area ground-floor
design features include a gable feature
with barn hip roof pitch roof dormer
windows a main hip roof a Juliet balcony
and a single-story rear projection the
dwelling with measure approximately six
point six meters to the ridge a four
point one meter to leave at the highest
point the rear projection would measure
perhaps only three point four meters and
height and extend about three meters
from the rear
the dwelling but vice plans have been
received during the course of the
application the Greenline turn on the
elevations indicate the changes so
previously it had a gable end and
they've now hit the roof which you can
see here and here and the dotted line
you can see they've reduced the height
slightly this lighter is proposed floor
plans and elevations for plot two it's
similar in design to plot one with
similar features but handed in its
layout so again you can see the green
dotted line from the previous and at
first floor four bedrooms were proposed
and a similar layout at ground floor but
just the opposite way around this slide
has a number of photographs which were
taken from Green Lane which identified a
character and design features available
with it the locality of the site
developments generally linear in form
along Green Lane and you've got two and
a half sorry one and a half I'd
single-story dwellings and some twos
draw elements as well located further to
the west this slide shows the locations
proposed access the first photograph
shows when proposed access would be
signed between stable craft shown to the
left of the image so this one here and
okhla tile shown to the right so the
access coming in here the next
photograph you can see the access coming
in being this location here upwards
house to the right and stable craft to
the left the bottom left image is
looking back towards Green Lane in a
southerly direction oak was house is
here and stable croft to the right with
its outbuilding just shown here the
application site is just in this
location where the dwellings were
proposed to be sited and this photograph
is looking up the proposed access the
application site is on the right to the
north is the entrance to the four
dwellings that have been approved and to
the left you've got stable craft
outbuilding in their garden to the left
beyond this photograph was taken from
within the application site looking
south towards Green Lane you see oak
woods house here and stable Croft and
the access is just behind this hedge
this photograph was taken from the rear
elevation of oak was house looking north
across the application site the
outbuilding which serves stable cross
it's visible just to the left here just
to give you a reference point and then
up to the north is the application site
for the four dwellings this slide shows
a photograph taken from the proposed
access to our stable Croft dwelling
which is also a B&B you can see private
manatee areas here
and as you look to the bottom-right the
image pans round there's also a patio
area here which they had stable craft
and it is a proposed access there are
number extent planning permissions which
are located within the application site
and within close proximity to the site
this slide shows a proposed site plan a
floor plan and elevations for the two
detached three-bedroom dwellings which
were proved on the application site
under planning permission 1600 672 full
so planning permission has already been
granted for two dwellings in a similar
location of this design and size the
access however was going down oak woods
house along the side and not sharing the
access with the four dwellings to the
north this permission is still extant
but no works have been carried out to
date to the north of the site planning
permission has been granted for erection
of four dwellings and this plan shows
our four dwellings approved to the north
of the site the two dwellings we're
considering are just in this location
here and the elevations show the
approximate layout the two types of
houses on the site this disk is a
flavour of what they would be like it's
noteworthy that works have now commenced
on this development at the north this
slide shows the approved plans for the
erection of replacement dwelling at oak
woods house so the two properties we're
considering here there's also an extent
permission for a replacement dwelling of
oak woods house and these are the
approved elevations for that development
and this permission is still extend that
know works appear to be carried out to
date to the southeast of the site lights
marry down which is attached Welling
this slide shows you proposed and
approved dwelling so this is
applications like oh sorry up here and
we've got another dwelling that's been
approved missus nixed out information
for a single dwelling in this location
just for reference purposes but no works
appear to have been carried out at this
point in time there were a number of
updates which have been circulated on
the update sheet the recommendation is
to grant an information to subject to
the conditions and notes outlined it's
on pages 33 and 34 of the committee
agenda thank you
Thank You Erin just to confirm this
application is only here because of
parish council objection yes okay
there's no one registered to speak for
this application I understand the ward
member would like to speak
councillor fielding so councillor
fielding welcome you have five minutes
don't really have to use it all over to
five minutes dealing with a parish
comments first their concern over the
housing mix if we can go to the Lee's
field development there are that has
been granted the access has been granted
planning permission the rest of the
dwellings are in a room waiting for
[Music]
reserve reserve matters sorry
apologies and they showed five
affordable or social housing properties
within that development therefore to a
great extent the comments on page 28 of
the document we've got the forest has
answered most of the questions with
regards to small or more accessible for
downsizing properties within the within
the village the original application was
for two houses which has was agreed on
appeal this application is for two
largest properties on the site do we
know what the the percentage increase
which I did ask for though you have the
neighbor who lives in Stoney Croft and
runs a B&B as approval as we have told
for four houses to the north of the site
access to Tony Croft site is over a
shared right-of-way that was negotiated
with the between the owners of the two
properties and this was a legal
agreement with a view of that this
development could take place the
applicant and the develop have worked
with SD Stratford district to make sure
that the complaints from the B&B owner
has been remedied by moving the line
site line back by a metre there's also
in Stoney cross garden
large shed that largely masks the two
proposed houses from from Stoney Croft
and there will be a tree screen planted
the other neighbor who who could be
affected is married on the owner of this
property has commented but has not
raised any objections the comments were
that this development was entirely in
keeping with the current small
developments in the village on pin on
page 28 which I've referred to the
officer sums up that the site is
suitable for two dwellings of the size
which we have before us thank you Thank
You counselor any questions for the ward
member okay it's council fielding thank
you so points clarification
councillor Mills thanks for children and
the entrance site has been approved yes
the extra stable crop it's already had
approval for four dwellings to the north
of the site which is separate from this
application the application will be
sharing the access as it adjoins here
down to the public highway all right
okay yeah okay that's fly for moment
thank you councillor Perry oh sorry I
thought you twitch into should get to
the debate oh sorry
Thank You mr. chairman it's very
disappointing to note that the Parish
Council aren't here we are only here
because of their objection which again
is if everybody's time so I would just
like to move forward that we go with the
officers recommendation and wish to
propose that think thanks was Jen
I think the whole thing to me is
absolutely appalling
I feel I've been fear but he's been to
this site if not I would urge a site
visit I would really urge if nobody's
been on it the society obviously John
has I don't know if anybody else has if
they've not put your hands up because I
think you deserve you need to go on a
site visit quickly it's appalling they I
think is infringement on human rights
here for them for this B&B you know I
personally I think it's just let their
business I mean it's just this entrance
that runs up the side and it goes round
the back and they believe it's just
appalling um I said it won't be a
supporting Office recommendation on this
mr. chairman but I urge I would urge a
site visit not really would okay well I
understand your concern they're already
there is already extant permission so
for this this application is only
altering what has already been approved
it may you may be fighting a battle has
already been lost to be honest I thought
the application was because these hands
were bigger and the barrage council
opposed it very councillor change them
on 11 turned up thumbkin to and I could
be a petitioner you we already have a
motion has been put forth by councillor
Perry but should have asked for a second
or immediately I didn't realize you were
going to put anywhere and alternative
arrangements so I'm going to ask for a
second to first council Perry's
councillor brain
I hear what councillor Miller says but
this would have been delegated to
officers of the parish cancer and asked
to come to us it's so disappointing that
parish councils waste this committee
star an officer's time writing report
let's go to the recommendation chairman
let me stay and not supporting their
parishes and I terrible after you're
gone I'm notable to go back to them
thank you thank you so it's proposed and
seconded will vote on this one and see
if we've come to your proposition if if
we need to
so the recommend a I saw the proposal is
to grant approve the application all
those in favor please
one two three four chairman and those
games won cheering abstentions
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 17 / 0 1 0 0
4 / ful I don't know if there's a
mechanism for us to send messages back
to parish via this because it's it's
just waste of time right item 6 on the
agenda is found on page 37 and it's
application reference 17 / 0 0 9 6 1 /
ful miss the homestead Potter's Lane
darling Scott this is the change of use
of land to garden land associated with
the homestead together with the
construction of garage and garden store
presenting officer again Erin Fetherston
over to you thank you the application
site lies to the northwest of darling
Scott settlement as identified by the
black dot on this plan this slide
identifies the application site outlined
in red the site lies adjacent to the
settlements Conservation Area which is
shown by the pink line to the south of
the site lies sundial house which is a
grade 2 listed dwelling identified on
this slide in red public footpath ss15 8
crosses the site traveling northwards as
shown by the green dashed line to the
north of the site public footpath SS 175
crosses from east to west as shown by
the green dashed line here to the public
footpaths Conservation Area line and
sundial house the grade 2 listed
building planning permission is sort of
the change of use of the existing
amenity land to garden land and the
erection of the attached outbuilding to
serve the homestead the homestead is a
dwelling located to the east of the
application site this is a homestead
here and it's garden and this is a site
revised plans have been sought and
forthcoming during the course of the
application in response to concerns
raised regarding returning area at the
foot of Potters Lane it's an informal
turning area so this is a superseded
block plan this was the extent of the
application previously beacons being
considered all of this area was proposed
as garden land
the revised proposed plumber looking at
now reduces it up so this access to
number six part is lane here doesn't
form part of the application that we
consume this evening this slider to
proposed outbuilding which comprises of
a garret and store building the building
is simple in design with pitch roof and
limited fenestration the height of the
widget the proposed buildings
approximately 4.6 meters at the highest
point and the outbuilding would measure
approximately eight point three meters
three metres at its widest point and
five point seven meters in depth at its
deepest point this slide show the
photograph of pot-herbs lane looking
northwards the extent of the public
highway finishes approximately where the
gates are visible beyond this point the
access becomes a private road you can
see the entrance and our house to the
south this light has a number of
photographs along Potter's Lane the top
left image is looking southwards close
to the gates identified in the first
slide looking back towards the road as
further down the second image you can
see here's a top right it formed the
gates looking northwards sundown houses
to the right and to the left the gardens
which serve the dwellings which rent
Potter's Lane again this image to the
bottom left is looking further up at the
gable of sundial house which is about
here towards the application site which
is at the top of the site top of the
road sorry and then this image is taken
from the turning area looking southwards
you can see the 20 long putters lane to
the right and sundial house gable just
here this slide shows a photograph of
six Potter's Lane and the area to the
south of the application site this is
the area in question which is now
excluded from the application site and
the vehicle access over two sticks
Potter's Lane which you can see here
this photograph is taken looking towards
the application site the public footpath
is visible to the right of the image and
travels along the homestead boundary in
this direction to the north this is a
homestead we can see in its garden to
the right and six Potter's Lane in its
garden and this is the application site
we're considering in the center of the
photograph this light has a photograph
taken
looking northwards across the
application site the outbuildings in the
garden of six Potter's Lane are visible
in this image you can see the boundary
to their garden
they're outbuildings here this is the
application site this photograph has
taken looking southwards from the public
footpath see the application site to the
right boundary of the homestead here and
the neighboring dwellings when the
Mystics the closest neighbor here this
was looking looking from the public
footpath got the homestead to the left
and the application site here heading in
a westward direction we can see the
outbuildings in six Potter's Lane garden
looking back in at least woods direction
the application site is here from the
other footpath because it crosses from
east to west and again this photograph
is taken from the public footpath which
travels north and Tory countryside and
the application site is here the
homestead to the left Mississippi of the
dwellings along Potter's Lane to the
right of the image there a number of
updates which have been circulated on
the update sheet the recommendation is a
grant plan information subject to the
conditions and notes outlined on pages
44 and 45 of the committee agenda and
our vision was contained within the
update sheet thank you
Thank You Erin get off the speaker
councillor Clayton please Cherrington
parish council welcome counselor thank
you so you have three meeting herbs
remute in three minutes three minutes
only if you remain seated any questions
at the end over to you good evening the
situation in Potter's lying as arisen
when all bit housing sold a parcel of
land this has led to much stress and
legal cost to all concerned this in the
main is due to the aforementioned round
at the end of this very narrow an
adopted line being used as a turning
circle by residents since the houses
were built this PDX Authority houses
I've been led to understand on some
residents property deeds it is stated as
such on there as also a robbery stop
that I have been led to understand on
some residents property deeds it is
stated as such and there is also a fire
hydrant on this land
although the applicant has made
alterations to their plans we the parish
council
residents were willing to drop our
objections on the condition a clear
understanding the turning circle would
remain for all to use unfortunately the
applicant has made no binding reference
to this in their planning application so
there is a concern that without legally
binding amendments at the planning stage
the residents are like that the
residents are at risk of losing their
only means of turning cars safely I
therefore urge this committee to insist
on an amendment prior to granting any
permission to carry out alterations or
development to this site thank you okay
questions and can O'Donnell good evening
and you mentioned about some of the
residents having a mention of the
turning circle area being there dudes if
their properties you have evidence of
that or is it simply hearsay the
residents themselves have this within
their deeds and it has been looked at
bali various solicitors thank you I
can't slow about you support this
application but took this little bit of
your comments you this turning circle
which isn't in the site has been agreed
what's happened is the turning circle
the land whether turn circle is was sold
at the same time to the same applicant
so it is bear land the problem is
although the new application shows the
buildings beyond the turning circle
there is no legal reference for it to
remain so that is the issue
technical councillor brain next Osaka
pairing it's it's really good evening
good evening council Katie um it was
really just clarification because
obviously you said you were supporting
this application on the 26th of June and
objecting can you I know you
Kassel abarnes picked up on some basis
sorry I'm still scared we were led to
believe sorry we would like to believe
that there would be a legally binding
contract of some sort which would ensure
the maintenance of this turning circle
would remain as a turning circle however
in the application that we supported
they did not actually make clear that
they would permanently allow this to
remain as a turning circle because
people who've bought the land although
they've put the buildings back that they
originally proposed to a new location it
still doesn't agree in any way legally
they're going to permanently leave that
for the residents to use and there's
been much legal wrangling
over this for the last couple of years
okay bones
other people other than this application
there any problem yes what is the
extremely narrow there's nowhere to turn
and this turning circle just to my own
personal language has been used as a
tendon circle by all those residents for
at least 40 years councillor fielding
well they're not driveways being you
saying that the orbit properties are on
the left-hand side of that of the track
on the other properties not have of
driveways up to them because orbits
normally provides sort of garages and
other accesses to houses now many of
them don't have Drive lights or other
axis and it is the only way of turning
down that line for visitors all the
residents is to go down their turn and
come back as they've been doing ever
since those houses have been built can
we go back because that was rather a
speedy charge through some features it
does show hoc cars parked
that's okay
not further down there perhaps we can
come back to the photos later in a point
of clarification any other questions
counselor thank you very much but if we
can go then to our walk member
councillor Saint please welcome counsel
st. Peter five minutes over thank you
I'll start by declaring my position
because although I've maintained an
objection I would like I would suggest
that effectively the application is
granted but not in the form that is
actually indicated on the officers
report what needs to be understood is
there are six houses built in the 1930s
in Potter's Lane that had an undocking
Road along there frontages they were
built before we have thought of cars
before we thought of garages and
therefore they are just exactly Alice
Lane and what had happened was for some
reason rather after they were
transferred from this council to the
housing associations 20 years ago the
the piece of land that's been referred
to as a turning a circle was actually
part of the highway and for some obscure
reason that was conveyed to the Housing
Association normally adopted roads are
maintained by unadopted rows on these
developments are maintained by this
council I know I have to budget for the
money for it so I can rest assured that
the effectively that is the case and
that's how the transfer deal was set
what has happened then was that Albin
Holmes decided to sell this piece of
highway to her neighbor which meant that
the occupants of number six Potter slain
and perhaps five and they are here
tonight had to actually drive over
somebody else's land to get into their
own plot of land so I was very much in
favor of the turning circle or the land
boundary being drawn back but that has
the disadvantage in that we have as a
planning authority no control over
somebody else's land that they had
originally applied to treat his garden
land just imagine trying to drive into
your own house driveway through somebody
else's garden unexpectedly after about
70 years of unrestricted access now
that's the situation that we have and
therefore although the garage plans are
acceptable and the idea of the parking
spaces on it are acceptable the
applicants can go to litigation to force
their out their own rights but I want us
to use the best planning conditions that
we have to control that piece of land
it's not a part of the application but
on the other hand what we need to do is
to ensure that the residents have
unrestricted access over what has always
been roadway and never should be
classified as land for garden purposes
you've got to have the access and as
councillor Clayton has just told us
you've got to actually get to that
bottom into that turning circle to
maneuver your car on pointed in a
direction to leave Potter's Lane so
happy to see it granted but we need some
clear conditions that effectively
restrict the owners of this land from
effectively constraining
people's access to their own property
and if we can do this under planning I
would be delighted
any questions yes sort of clarification
really what you're saying is this is
turning circle isn't in the application
but it is owned by the person that has
got the application yes and it was in
the application but if they with droney
to try and overcome the objections that
I and others race or it isn't at this
present time in the application
I'm sure Aaron will carry for that part
okay you would accept that if it's not
within the application area we can't
apply conditions to an area or to a
piece of land outside of the application
area conditions you should apply should
be on the is in the application so the
piece of land hatched in blue on the
right hand photo at the moment there the
application site was reduced to that yes
so that's that you accept that's the bit
that we're looking at today correct I
think it could be point for
clarification and maybe you mace but we
I'm not sure if we can I'll do it
are we able to no cherries not part of
the application site it's not necessary
I've got a few points okay we'll come
back okay I just wanted to ask you up
while we're on the topic so we don't get
confused all right any other questions
for the ward member councillor fielding
are we asking the applicant to dedicate
the turning area well that would be the
ethical thing to do but as Mason will
point out to you that's not part of the
application site what you have it's got
an application site
okay and the rest of the land by default
hopefully will be retained as highways
but on the reports chairman
it says reference number note number
three on page forty five reference to
rights of access across learning area
now if someone thinks that we can put
that in across an area land in blue
south of application site I think I'm
really stressing that we need to do that
for the benefit of the residents but put
it in a way that's plus enforceable with
the planning okay are there any other
questions okay
Thank You counselor said points of
clarification Katz Laban's feeling and
parent sorry to speak again mr. chairman
but if they have an established use over
the area it's not in our remit to change
it is for them to to do that took us
point of clarification I don't know what
we're talking about something even in
the application side but if they have
been using it for seventy years they
will establish use can I just ask mace
to go over the point in terms of the
remit and that the powers of this
committee am i right in saying that we
can only determine conditions even
thought those areas within the site
correct not within the ownership of the
applicant
you're not considering the actual
turning circle so effectively we can't
use the planning process to do a good
deed for other people in this case at
all you cannot the difference is chair
is that we're a planning committee we're
considering planning matters but we're
getting into the realms
prescriptive rights we took property
matters you should be separated right
I've got a couple other people
indicating counselor brain complicated
ones don't leave chairman I mean the
right way over this land that belongs to
the people who got the application I'm
it's a civil matter it's not for us as a
planning committee to decide so we've
got two options really if we support
cancer st. then we have to refuse the
application and ask for another one to
come back that's what they would do or
we go with the application as it is
that's what we're left with on the frame
in my opinion sounds like we're going
into debate slightly but you are I agree
with what you're saying actually any
other points of clarification should we
go to the debate no years okay I think
you were saying what they were all
thinking actually so council fielding
these neighbors rather than leave it up
to us to see effective the garden you're
suggesting we would defer to come back
with a better plan yes I think we would
need correct me if wrong if somebody we
would need planning reasons to do that
what what I think you're suggesting is
we would defer it based on things that
aren't planning reasons and that's again
I don't think within the remit of the
committee it's a civil matter it's not I
don't want to be going outside of what
is our territory make sure number six
does have a right over the turn so cos
is next door it has to grow out of the
tenant circle to get onto Potter's plane
so that's number six sorted numbers one
and two when I checked they only go up
to the extent of their property they do
not go further into the turning circle
that's not to say they have don't do not
have a prescriptive right they may do
but that is a property matter and that's
up to the owners of those properties to
take it further through civil civil
matters civil ways it's not the remit of
this committee to discuss those matters
punished on course and so I've got
council Perry means it's the merit in
actually going back and having a look at
the site and having a site visit know
what would your planning grounds be I
was not disagree with you I was thinking
the same thing I think we would need to
have some concern regarding the
application itself for astrocyte visit I
think it's complicated
forgetting the civil civil matters I
think we need to see the layout of the
site to determine this application what
I've seen on that it doesn't show me a
lot of unfortunate councillor bugs I
don't think that we can refuse this
application I'm quite happy to propose
the application with a note on to say
that we have a discussion we are
concerned about the existing turning
circle although it's not on the site as
they note and that as far as I can see
is as far as I can go in alleviating the
possible problem there is we don't know
there is a problem but and there's those
council are supporting us really so
that's not the first one I will propose
it but I didn't think we ought to put a
note on or something supplied by a
solicitor they can read and write better
than make two to guarantee that the
people are able to have access to them
okay so proposal that we grant the
application there is already a note on
their voice on this matter so it's
already there yeah okay
we counsel fielding next I'll come back
Joe no people on its peak SATs okay
counts feeling council brain mates
I think counselor Saints put us into
quit in a bit of a dilemma because he's
agreeing that we should discuss and only
approve the garden which is what the
application is which I'm happy to go
along with but as part councillor bars
is referring to there's got to be a
rider of some sort about getting the
turning circle sorted out which we can't
deal with its his goodwill procedurally
and I just wanna make sure clear this
I've got a proposal on glass whether
we've got a seconder at this point or
not okay Cass millisecond counts a brain
joined come back it's it's impacting on
the neighbors immunity so you would
propose a site visit so I've got a
seconder as well I'll go through them in
order unless of course a bill hearing
the reasons that the councillor brain
has put that we would have a deferral
for a site visit is the proposer of the
first recommendation account so bound
would you retract your proposition in
favor of Casa brained proposition for a
site visit so we have a proposition to
defer for a site visit so we can
establish the harm that the garden would
cause on the neighbor amenities because
we're concerned about that as well and
we're not that concerned about the
access is purely for us to look at the
garden access a garden impact council
fielding
stands at the moment he the owner owns
the land and he can stop anybody turning
in that area so it's okay don't worry
we'll move all from that because that's
not for this committee okay we have a
proposition to defer it's been seconded
all those in favor of deferring for a
site visit please show one to six
chairman committee resolves to defer
application reference 17 / 0 0 9 6 1 /
ful pending a site visit excellent
ok 1 2 I 2 8 can we have a break for a
moment people need to come for break
when minute okay two minutes three
minutes real quick
item eight our final item tonight
then is on page 61 this application
reference 17 / 0 1 9 6 8 / ful is for
halfway house 67 ships and Road older
minster and is for the proposed first
floor and thoughts aside and two-story
rear extension presenting officer Andy
Carter Andy OH to you Thank You chair
the center of the screen the sight is
indicated by the black dot and here you
have a overview slide to indicate the
application site the building is
actually part of a semi-detached it's
indicated with the arrow there the plan
at the top of the page shows the the
site area of the house in question and
the plans are the base of that slide
indicates the the area of the extension
and so extending to the rear to the side
over the existing ground floor side wing
the elevations give you that in a little
bit more clarity so you can see the
existing elevations in white and front
elevation shows that single story
element to the side
the proposal puts a an upper floor on
top of that and then looking at the side
elevations both ground floor and upper
floor then extend back by approximately
I think it's 3 meters in distance the
floor plans extrapolate that on so in
terms of internal space it's creating an
additional reception area at ground
floor with an additional bedroom and
ensuite facility at first law this is
the property in question
it's a 1960s tell property semi-detached
that's the view from the front within
the garden view from the side that's the
the single storey element that would
have the first-floor element above it
and then with the the two-story
eliminate extending back into the garden
that's the neighbor's garage from with
studio above from the host God and
another photograph from within the site
and a further photograph and then we
have a view of the garage of the
neighboring property a couple of other
plans that are worth showing you are
these one that isn't on screen now if I
could just get the cursor to work well
anyway the property on the right-hand
side of the screen as you look at it is
the property to be extended the property
on the left-hand side of the screen is
an extent permission so any house that
has been approved within the garden of
the application site so what it would
have the effect of is with the addition
of the the new extension the proposed
extension would further reduce the size
of the garden of the host property I'm
advised that the the approved house that
you can see on that plan that was
approved in 2015 has service in 2015
yes it was has been implemented they
have commenced works on that and that
gives you this these elevations give you
an indication of apologies for the
resolution give you an indication of the
proposed house sorry the granted house
next to the proposed extension so it has
the effect of reducing the garden size
the recommendation is to is to grant
this side extension okay we got our
first speaker
Maria Norman please parish Clarke
welcome thank you for waiting around for
so long as well so you have three
minutes if you'd arranged the city to
further varia questions at the end
please
so really the concerns that the Parish
Council have in relation to this
application in part because of the size
of the extension which will
significantly reduce the available
garden space one of the features of
Alderman stay is that most the vast
majority of houses do have very very
generous Gardens you've drawn attention
to the planning permission that was
granted in July 2015
for this two-story three-bedroom
dwelling the effect of it is as that as
you can see from there or if you like to
get back to well is is that you've got
two houses crammed cheek-by-jowl into a
very very small area and as far as the
parish council is concerned our
interpretation of the core strategy is
that any alterations and modifications
should take into account the site
location and the cumulative impacts of
previous extensions and development on
the site where appropriate so our view
here is that the the development is is
too much it's a neighbor development of
the plot this particular interpretation
of course strategy 20 is something that
the parish council has been concerned
about for quite some time because it
appears to us that the developments that
have been permitted in the village are
too great for the plot size available
and because we have one other
application pending which is apparently
scheduled Ruth for refusal because it is
again going to be too big for the sites
yet this is one where the parish council
believes in fact it is entirely
appropriate and in keeping what we're
really looking for is some clarity of
interpret
of course strategy 20 say that we can
deal with these applications in a more
consistent fashion we don't see that
they are consistent at the moment thank
you any questions the parish council
okay in that case thank you very much
go to our ward member counter O'Donnell
all right welcome back five minutes over
to you
good evening committee this evening I'm
speaking in support of the parish
council I think their concerns raised
regarding cs20 is really worth your
consideration because whilst all of us
are keen for homeowners to remain in
locality and as we all wish to realize
the full potential of their property
they are rightly concerned to God in a
scale of the extension given the mission
for the new dwelling and if you look on
the plan which round is left up it
really is quite a tight fit and it looks
very different to how the plot is shown
on Google Earth when we viewed it
yesterday and also we'd questioned the
design the extension is it truly
subservient to the original house it's
not it's no true indication - actually
it's an extension when you look back at
the designs as I drove past today I
noted that the front of the property's
hedge border had been opened up and
there's work underway which indicates
perhaps that the new dwellings off being
started on and it did appear to make the
plot look a lot tighter given also the
fact that the constraints of the new
dwelling set by SDC were impact upon
neighboring occupiers character of the
area and a nearby listed building I
think it's really worth noting that if
this goes through we were changing the
street scene because you'll suddenly
have three two storey buildings in a row
and you keep resetting your precedent
and I think that given that there is
another property in the village
Marlborough house which just seems to be
continually being developed and extended
and has now led to have development of
the plot I think the parish council are
quite rightly concerned that this could
start to happen throughout alder Minster
and I think we do need to remind for the
cumulative impact of continued extension
such as has happened elsewhere
because the price counts are quite
rightly fearful of it repeating itself
with this application I think if it does
go through at least have a condition
that would be no more extension to it
and there yeah and I would just ask you
to not support the office
recommendations of approval Thank You
counsel
any questions for the ward member please
yes counselor Mills my opinion okay
will there been any consultation between
the developer on the post counsel if you
know between the applicant I'm not sure
I don't believe her husband no there
wasn't at the they weren't there at the
project council meeting when this is
okay thanks any further questions that
case counselor Donnell thank you very
much okay once clarification cats
fielding which came with the paperwork
the black area is totally different to
where so have some difficulty finding
the proper lead counsel it quite right
the scallop at that Chairman's briefing
earlier only yes I should have picked
that up counselor that the black area on
your papers is erroneous but the site
plan on here is correct apologies for
that can we go back to that site plan
shows the property on the left-hand side
is that correct
it shows the application property and
then the going back to the lam sorry yes
it's a rather different and I must have
met I was looking at this earlier
because this not been the case officer
for this so was how should we say
providing this on the hoof there's a
very different as you say plotline
related to that property on the right
there looks like it's sort of been
knocked over on it
I think that is is an architect's how
should we say stroke of pen is it trying
to show the adjoining building it is
trying to show they're joining building
because it's quite an unusual
semi-detached range meant it but both
properties aren't equal in effect which
you would normally find when summer to
touch the the property adjoining kind of
dog legs around it doesn't show is how
tight which is being referred to by the
parish council the the building is up to
the garden boundary which seems to be
part and parcel of their argument and
yet you go back to the other plans you
can see a much larger garden than is
shown in that image yes correct
I mean if we looked at what's shown on
this plan which was from the 2015
approval for the the additional infill
dwelling then doing some measurements of
what garden size would be left to number
67 we would have with the extension were
it approved the garden size would be 91
square meters the bringing it down from
101 because the footprint of the
extension is 10 square meters so there's
there's still quite a large garden area
available should the extension be
approved the garden size for the house
that was approved in 2015 is 81 square
metres slightly smaller but was that's
obviously not up for grabs at this
committee that's as an approved dwelling
properties share the same drive no they
do share the same drive in that proposed
scheme there so that that driveway would
come from
the Stratford Road so ships tomorrow
should say and will then create almost a
turning area on site any other points of
clarification so should we go to the
debate get some bonds well it seems a
bit contrived to me in this concern over
the Parish Council and the ward member
I'm wondering although I didn't vote for
the busy that's done but I'm just
wondering this is a few miles away
whether we should I'd be quite happy to
go there at the same time council brain
the same thing actually so I'm up it's a
second that proposal all right should
anybody else want to speak on this
I've seen it is a bit sure I think they
do although I've seen it would recommend
right I know just if that's what people
are thinking I'm content to go that I'm
actually I've got some reasons against
out of just okay right okay what reasons
we stay tuned to go sip because you want
to ascertain what a better understanding
of the site layer scale this is thing
I've written down which isn't but I'm
very consumer right I'm not sure the
drawings are inaccurate it's I just
think they're showing two different
applications had me out the egg India we
could have asked a lot of their
questions and they haven't got one so
the only ways haven't actually look it
does look a bit contrived to make we
have reasons
okay we have reasons it's been proposed
and seconded that we defer this recite
visits for the reasons mentioned okay
those in favor please show ya pivoting
therefore resolves to defer this
application knows our outcome Caprica
so we'll defer application reference 17
/ 0 1 9 6 8 ful to a later date if you
want to hang around and work out dates
site visits committee that would be a
good idea the meeting is now closed
thank you